okay let's get to audience questions
first one very timely next week we have
the second set of Democratic 2020
primary debates viewer wants to know hey
David it does Bernie debating with
Warren in the second debate help or hurt
either or both of them yeah so last time
Elizabeth Warren was on night one and
Bernie Sanders was on night two there's
sort of two answers to this question one
is let's deal with the specifics is it
better or worse for Bernie and Warren to
be on the same night given that they are
appealing to a largely similar wing of
the Democratic Party before we even get
to that remember
eventually it's going to be just one
night this entire thing of having two
nights is only happening because there
are way too many candidates including a
ton of candidates who have no chance
whatsoever so understand that on the
first night along with Elizabeth Warren
and Bernie Sanders Tim Ryan is going to
be on the stage the guy has zero shot
Marianne Williamson is going to be on
the stage Amy Klobuchar Delaney
Hickenlooper Bullock they have no chance
and the only reason why we're even
talking about the possibility of them
being split up on separate nights is
because there are so many candidates and
it's pushing the debate into two nights
that ends after this debate they're
going to be on the same debate stage
eventually so the conversation applies
only to one more debate but let's
actually play it out if they're
appealing too widely the same slice of
the Democratic Party are they better off
Warren and Bernie by debating on
separate nights and being on each of
their respective nights the sort of
prominent progressive choice or are they
better off on the same night in order to
create the perception which is not an
inaccurate perception that there are
multiple good choices if your priority
is a more progressive candidate
particularly when it comes to the
primary economic issues of inequality
and economic fairness and so on and so
forth I believe that they are better off
on the same night they are two of the
most prominent candidates if you look at
who is in the lead right now its Biden
Bernie Warren Harris and then is it's
Buddha judge Biden and Harris are on
night two Buddha judge Warren
and Bernie are on night one and by being
there together my hope is and we'll see
if it actually is borne out by their
performance that they are going to
eclipse everybody else who is on that
stage as clearly being the folks who are
the furthest to the left and have the
specific ideas and understanding of the
issues Bullock's gonna be a non-factor
Pete Buddha judge is climbing he's just
desperate to climb his polling has gone
nowhere if he wants to be in this thing
he has to make a move to get closer to
the top four candidates he is going to
be trying really hard but he has a lot
of trouble talking about substance I
think Bernie and Warren are gonna do
really well in relation to Pete Buddha
judge Delaney and Hickenlooper they're
not gonna be factors Amy Klobuchar often
embarrasses herself and last debate she
did terribly I can't imagine she's going
to do much better or Roark imploded in
the last debate and he'll be lucky to
avoid any possible gaffes
Tim Ryan looked shell-shocked during the
entire last debate can't imagine he'll
do much and marianne williamson
has this sort of funny cult following
but she doesn't really have a shot so
Bernie and Sanders being together I
think is going to show how strong the
serious detail-oriented policy oriented
progressive wing of this primary is and
I think that that's going to be a really
good thing for them assuming of course
that the timing and the spread of the
questions is not unfair in some way
assuming that the format even though
it's designed to prevent actually by
definition serious depth on issues
allows Bernie and Warren to really show
how much more detail-oriented and how
much how much more sophisticated their
understanding of a lot of these
political political issues is compared
to the other candidates if the format
allows that if the moderators allow that
to some degree I think it will be a
really good thing for Bernie and Warren
to be up there together my guess is you
will start to hear discussions after in
next week's debate of there should be a
Bernie Warren ticket warned Ebert Bernie
Warren Warren Bernie whatever your sort
of preference is my expectation is that
assuming things go as they often do with
both of them
in their respective debates that is a
conversation that's going to be
happening I'm not worried about them
being on the same stage and more
importantly by the third debate they
will be on the same stage because there
won't be enough candidates to justify
two nights